good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight at 11 I'm Brian Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez a popular home builder
across the valley getting some pushback
from its homeowners as several residents
in the Cadence Community say their new
builds are not complete many having to
wait a year or more for those repairs to
get fixed Madison Kimbrough joining us
from the Cadence neighborhood in
Henderson now with more
neighbors are not too happy with their
home builder Richmond American Homes as
many say they've been given the
runaround when it comes to home repairs
and feel that there's been a lack of
quality control from the start living in
that mass for four months
um
and not having
our bathroom which you know when you buy
a new home you expect it things to be
right homeowner Lisa Jones lives in the
newly developed housing community of
cadence in Henderson she and her husband
moved in two years ago but since then
they have noticed a plethora of problems
with their house built by Richmond
American Homes there's a lot of things
that were flawed or scratched or just
not right from the poor paint job to
cracks in the wall to collapsing shelves
in their kitchen pantry the list goes on
and Lisa's Not Alone Michael bourde
showing us around his home barday says
he's only lived there for 11 months I
noticed that you know there's a bulge in
the wall first floor I noticed there is
a broken
um
cabinet on top I am the one who's
supposed to leave here I'm the one that
actually is seeing you know uh crickets
coming underneath the you know stairs or
dropping from the ceiling in the
bathroom bourde reached out to Richmond
America but they stalled on getting any
repairs done so we eventually reached
out to the Better Business Bureau for
help fellow homeowner Jeff OS who spoke
to eight news now on the phone says he's
beyond frustrated at this point but he
is standing his ground we're prepared to
take legal action I mean they they keep
dumping things uh against us about you
know how they how they don't cover
things anymore well these things were
identified well before the year uh which
puts them under the warranty which makes
them their problem and not ours we
reached out to Richmond American Homes
about the issues but they had no comment
in Henderson Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now
now if you're in a similar situation
what can you do well according to the
Nevada state contractors board you can
file a complaint with them against
licensed contractors for up to four
years after the work is completed they
also recommend that you check any
contracts or warranties you might have
before you go ahead and file a comp a
claim we have posted a link to the
contractors board's website at
8newsnow.com